very much for coming on the program mr.
Corben so it feels like there is renewed
optimism about the chances of some kind
of brexit deal being agreed now I know
these are only reports at this stage but
from what you've heard is it something
that you think labor could support not
that I've heard so far although as you
say it is unsubstantiated reports I
think the problem areas of regulation
and deregulation which come from
whatever trade arrangement there is with
Europe and the wider world but also
perhaps very seriously is the Irish
border issue and if it creates a border
down the Irish Sea rather than on the
Irish border itself I can see that being
problems and with that in mind how would
you treat any Labour MP that did decide
to back this deal if it does come back
to the House of Commons well I'll talk
to them about it but at the moment we're
actually dealing with hypotheticals so
I'm not even draw the Prime Minister
knows what the deal is going to be as
yet and so we'll obviously have a
discussion about it within the
parliamentary Labour Party and with
colleagues and decide how we go from
here but our principles are around the
five pillars that I put forward in my
letter to reason may some months ago and
what we structured which is of a customs
union with the European Union a trade
arrangement and protection of consumer
environment than working rights and
crucially the support for the Irish
peace process which remember that Good
Friday Agreement is not a bilateral
agreement it's an international
agreement it's treating the same time
though this is the defining critical
issue at the moment you will have a
position on whether or not to back any
deal that comes if it labrum he goes
against your agreed line could they have
the widt withdrawn we will decide what
our voting process is when we know what
the deal is I can't really answer a
question on whether we support a deal or
not which we haven't yet seen and I
don't think any Labour MP is yet able to
answer that question either would you be
more likely to back any deal if it was
put to a complimentary referendum I
think many in Parliament not necessarily
Labour MPs but others might be more
inclined to support it even if they
don't really agree with the deal but I
would caution them on this because my
view would be
that I would want a deal that resembles
the five pillars that we put forward and
that obviously would command support and
obviously does have wide support within
the Labor Party and the trade unions but
don't you need to compromise a bit I
mean if it was put to a referendum you
could argue in that referendum that it
was a bad deal I want us to protect
those workers rights consumer and
environmental rights I want us to have
that trade relationship with Europe look
in the week when Nissan says there's a
question mark over Sunderland because of
the possibility of an Odile exit from
the European Union and we're already
seeing job losses across the country and
we're seeing siren calls from businesses
and unions all over the country about
job losses I think we've got to be very
very cautious so again I know we are in
a hypothetical still but if a deal does
come back next week or towards the end
of next week
what should come first a second
referendum or a general election we have
to get a deal that we can agree on if
possible and the Labour position is that
we would take this to a public vote
under a Labour government which within
three months we would hope to reach
agreement with the European Union we
leave that to be possible along the
lines that we've set out and within six
months hold a referendum and a Labour
government would then implement the
results of that referendum between a
sensible relationship with Europe and
remain so just to be clear it sounds
like you're going for an election first
and then a referendum will look at the
any deal that comes up but before we
trigger an election and when should an
election be well it obviously depends
what happens this week but we have a
government that is now in -40 hasn't yet
one of vote in parliament and having the
Queen's speech and the State Opening of
Parliament tomorrow is ludicrous as we
alluded in fact is a party political
broadcast from the steps of the throne
so do you think there should be an
election before Christmas is that the
kind of time frame you're looking at
that is obviously a strong possibility
but listen we're ready for election any
times I want to go out there on a garden
and campaign on health on housing on
ending Universal Credit on investment
for the future on the green industrial
revolution all the things that our party
has very strong and very exciting
policies on but it's in your hands
surely
one as soon as possible she is not into
it before we we're not a majority in
parliament were but we're not but if the
government wants an election a new back
in elections and you'll get an election
if over 430 MPs vote for an election
there is an election it's the fixed in
Parliament act is not an either/or it is
a an aggregation of those that vote for
it those that vote against don't count
now we've been talking a bit about what
would happen if a deal is brought back
next week but of course there is still a
big chance that No Deal is agreed and
according to the Ben Act if there isn't
a deal agreed by next weekend then Boris
Johnson must request an extension to
brexit if he doesn't
when will you hold a vote of confidence
he is under a legal obligation if no
deal has been agreed by Parliament to
write the letter send a letter that has
been passed by the EU number two that
because you call it the Ben Act if he
doesn't do that he's in there in breach
of the law so what would you do then
we'd obviously take parliamentary action
against him at that point
and is that advertiser by legislation or
vote of confidence and and if of course
he loses a confidence vote then there'll
be two weeks for someone else to come
forward become Prime Minister request
that extension now I know that you as
leader of the Opposition clearly feel
does that should be you of course I'm
the leader of the Opposition their whole
precedent all the British parliamentary
precedents going back as long as you
care to look that the first option is
the leader of the Opposition be invited
to form an administration in order to
deal with specific points as perfect
points being to make sure we get a deal
with the European Union but if you can't
get the numbers and I know you want to
and you think you should but if you
can't get the numbers could you consider
backing someone else if it is the way to
stop an odor like that I'm not going to
hypotheticals we will form an
administration if this government
collapses with the purpose of a deal and
take this country forward to decide its
own future through an election and the
people get a chance to decide their
future through a referendum after all a
referendum made its decision in 2016
this would be a decision time between
remain and hopefully some reforms or
leave under the terms that I've outlined
because if you won't even consider the
of someone else leading a temporary
government then some of our viewers may
conclude that actually you prioritize
getting to number 10 over stopping a No
Deal break set my priority is that our
Parliament should decide what the future
should be in the immediate sense that
all the precedents are the leader of the
Opposition is invited to form an
administration
I've been holding meetings with all of
the opposition parties regularly in my
office we are agreed on stopping a No
Deal exit from the European Union and as
a result of that significant progress
has been made in Parliament such as the
passage of the Ben Act is there
agreement and other things obviously not
Europe where opposition parties that
don't agree on a whole range of
political issues but I think I've shown
that the Labour Party is more than
prepared to work with others in the
interests of protecting this country
from the dangers of an Odile exit it
sounds a bit like you know the meat loaf
approach of BRICS that you'll do
anything to stop a No Deal apart from
that that's a one thing you just won't
contact I will do everything to stop a
No Deal
exit including offering us to be a
interim obviously minority
administration but the specific point of
reaching an agreement and taking the
country forward to give the people a
choice so if you were in that position
can you guarantee that you would only
request an extension and then a call in
an election you would not implement a
single piece of Labor Party policy well
we wouldn't have a majority to get any
legislation through anyway so that is
not an option we are not a majority
party in Parliament obviously I wish we
were our purpose would be because well I
don't think there'd be much point
because you Derek majority to get things
so obviously immediate issues that come
up whilst that government is in office
albeit for probably a very short time
would have to be dealt with things
happen around the world things happen
around the country governments have to
act so you can't rule out and
implementing those they can you can't
you can never say never about that but
the point of the government would be a
short-term government in order to take
things forward okay now we know of
course that labor want to see a
referendum on
so in that referendum would you campaign
to leave or remain what we'd hold is a
special Labour Party conference when
we've reached the agreement the European
Union and that party conference would
decide what we would do the point of it
is we would have an option of remaining
and I would personally hope reforming
within the European Union I said as I
said in the last referendum campaign or
leaving on these terms which are trade
which are regulations and crucially
protecting the Good Friday Agreement
because can you not see people's
exasperation I guess that you can't
really say how you would campaign in a
room with a party that tries to bring
people together we have people who are
labour voters are both voted leave and
remain and obviously they have different
opinions on that but they have the same
opinions on ending Universal Credit on
the green Industrial Revolution on
investment on the poverty of seaside
towns such as we're in in at the present
time that's what brings people together
we give people that choice but a brexit
is arguably the biggest political
decision since you know the end of World
War two so we and people are looking to
you for leadership remember though that
you're sitting on the fence no we're
bringing that way I'm giving people a
choice a choice between remaining or
leaving with these terms at the moment
the only thing on offer seems to be
Boris Johnson taking us over a cliff and
let's move on from practicing we are
here in Hastings if Labour in government
what would you do to help coastal towns
like this one well first of all coastal
towns have a uniquely difficult
situation at the present time income
levels average income levels are about
fifteen hundred pounds less than inland
towns partly because of changes in
tourist industry partly because of loss
of fishing industry and partly because
of deindustrialization which happened in
many places yet seaside town is a very
important place that people live and
they need investment will need support
one starting with will be doing a green
Industrial Revolution which will be an
investment in offshore wind electricity
generation projects and we'll be setting
up a an electricity company a peoples
electricity company some of the profits
of which will be invested in those
seaside towns for people to decide the
future of them but we'll also be ending
Universal Credit which is a big factor
in many seaside towns has led to a great
deal of poverty
has led to the freezing of benefits and
has led to sadly with the implementation
of the capability of work assessment
tests people even take their own lives
out of desperation
so for seaside towns it's going to be
investment it's going to be spending
money on offshore wind projects it's
going to be also improved infrastructure
projects through region investment funds
in this country the poorest seaside
towns are actually all around on the
south coast where we are at the moment
north east coast north west coast and it
does mean that we have to have a much
better regional policy in this country
and so we will be having yes a national
investment bank but we'll be having
regional transformation funds where the
region's themselves English regions will
decide on how that money is spent and
obviously we parallel opportunities in
Scotland and Wales there was research
that was looking at earlier and from the
Department of Education earlier this
year which said that in seaside towns
like Hastings and elsewhere
disadvantaged pupils are on average
getting three GCSE grades lower than
elsewhere now at labour conference
delegates came up with a pretty radical
policy to try and tackle disadvantages
in the education system the abolition of
private schools so is that labor policy
labor policy is to make sure that
private education is not a charity but
pays tax just like anybody else and that
the local education Authority has far
more influence over the way in which
education operates obviously we'll be
deciding exactly what goes on is the
manifesto the key point will be a
national education service which will
guarantee free nursery places for all
two to four year olds properly funded a
primary and secondary schools ending key
stage one and two testing an inspection
system which isn't Ofsted which instead
is HMI Majesty's Inspectorate of
Education much more supportive system
and crucially equality of opportunity
for both apprenticeships and University
and ending University fees there's a big
difference though isn't there between
ending the charitable status at the
private schools and getting rid of them
so which is it what do you want to see I
want to see all children basically in
good quality publicly funded schools
that's what my ambition
and I would therefore be supporting
better investment the better running of
state schools particularly comprehensive
schools my ferret if there weren't
private schools I think private schools
are often seen as a slight and elitist
thing children only go there because
their parents can afford it or are
prepared to make the sacrifices to try
to get them there what I'd much rather
is investment in the public sector
schools where all children get an
advantage what we have is a country
where opportunity is often denied to the
poorest people because they live in the
poorest areas that often have the worst
schools and the worst opportunities you
quite rightly pointed out that
achievements of students in seaside
towns is sometimes less than other
places that is a reflection often of
poverty and of the prevalence of the
private rented sector and insecure
housing which often means children move
schools we've got to radically change
the approach to people's lives you go
into the election with the policy to
abolish private schools what was on the
table what will go into the election for
is the establishment of a national
education service which will properly
fund all states I know I know it isn't
and we'll end the charitable status of
private schools as to the other parts of
it that is out for discussion at the
moment within our party before it goes
into our manifesto okay and conference
also voted for a very ambitious target
to have a net zero emissions by 2030 if
that is going to happen there's going to
be have to be some pretty radical
policies so is that policy that target I
want to achieve that if we can there are
obviously huge hurdles towards achieving
it does mean a radical change in the way
in which we generates electricity it
does mean huge investment in green
energy it also means a huge number of
jobs being created in green energy and
it also means significant changes to
agriculture and industrial practice and
it also means flights as well doesn't it
if you're going to be serious about
meeting that kind of a mission you're
going to have to look at potentially
restricting flights it's like it also
means measuring properly at the moment
the government is often not including
Airlines and shipping or aircraft and
shipping in the measurement of emissions
and we're not including the emissions
created through imported goods that we
have but let's be serious about this the
world as a whole
is suffering global warming the world as
a whole is destroying the natural world
at a very rapid rate we have to do
everything not just to protect but to
enhance our biodiversity we have to have
trade policies that reflect that and we
have to have domestic policies in this
country that reflect that so if nothing
else the extinction rebellion has woken
people up to the seriousness of this and
I think all of us have to recognize that
yes does it mean in the long term more
efficient aircraft and fewer flights
probably yes it means that moving
towards more efficient railways and
railways in this country need more
investment I believe but also it's very
easy to take Eurostar from London to
Brussels or Paris it's actually
incredibly expensive to take a train
anywhere else in Europe and flight is
often a fifth or less than the cost of a
train that surely needs to be looked at
all those kind of issues a train is much
more sustainable way of transport than
thing you should think there should be
higher taxes implying not necessarily
high taxes but improving land forms of
transport as a way of reducing emissions
we've all got to do something about it
but we have to recognize if we don't
then the problems are going to get worse
I mean you've said and that you fly as
little as possible now and that you
would continue to try and do so as Prime
Minister I mean is that really realistic
can you really have a prime minister who
is you know spending hours on a train
trying to get to summit since I want
such an efficient way of your time a
good train journeys an extremely
efficient most of the time because you
could there you can use a computer you
can use your phone you can have
conferences you can talk to people and
it is not polluting the environment this
same extent that an aircraft as I travel
when I go to the UN they want to of
courses of course if you're going
transatlantic it's a bit difficult to
take a train I get that but Western
Europe is not particularly a problem and
I travel always by train now and I spend
yeah I do spend a lot of time on trains
but do you know what I used the time as
efficiently as I possibly can on trains
and I enjoy the journeys now and if
there is an election I know you want to
win a majority of course but we've all
seen the polls it is very possible that
the only way that you could get into
number 10 is with the support of smaller
parties so if the price of the s
he support was a second independence
referendum in Scotland is that something
you could agree to if we win an election
we win an election and we form a Labour
government with all the transformative
policies that I've outlined we are not
going to coalition with anybody we will
put our program forward in Parliament
what I've said on the Scottish
referendum is it's not our priority we
want to put 70 billion pounds of
investment into Scotland and we would
certainly not Campton sit in the early
days of early years of a Labour
government because I think the 2014
referendum was supposed to be a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity see there
be some in Scottish Labour who were
really worried about this this is your
opportunity to absolutely rule it out
it's very clear we're not going into
coalition with anybody and I've made
that very clear here and in Scotland way
that you could give the green light to a
second independence referendum if it
meant that you could get what I've said
is that we don't think independence is a
good idea the income and expenditure
figures for Scotland indicate that an
independent Scotland would face massive
austerity and and loss of public ruling
out no but I'm saying that we would
invest in Scotland and we wouldn't even
countin sit in the early years of a
Labour yeoman I've said that very
clearly in Scotland as well as here ok
now john macdonald gave an interview
with GQ earlier this week and he said he
was asked if you'd stay on as Labour
leader if you lost an election and he
said I think it's the same for my own
personal position I can't see so what we
do is ask tradition which is to have an
election for a new leader so we're going
to ask you directly if you lose the next
election we stand down as leader we're
not expecting to lose the next elections
it's john macdonald gave an honest
answer why can't it's a hypothetical
question and it's up to the members of
our party to decide who the leader is
john macdonald gave an answer he gave an
answer that's right does he Johnny
John's gave an answer to an interview
that he undertook my answer is this I'm
leading this party to go into an
election we have hundreds of thousands
of members determined to win that
election I am utterly determined to get
a message out dates only labor is going
to end us
and invest in a future a better future
for this country and I want to lead the
party to do that John MacDonald also
says he thinks that the next leader
should be a woman do you think the next
leadership you're a woman it's not for
me to decide who the next leader is
obviously a woman will be a candidate of
that I'm very very sure I'd also point
out that since I became leader they've
been more women appointed to our front
bench and Shadow Cabinet never before
there are more all-women shortlists and
the next parliamentary Labour Party will
in all probability be a majority women
membership any particular rising star
I'm still leader there's lots of rising
stars and they're utterly brilliant
people and I enjoy working with them and
campaigning with all of them but I am
NOT into the business of ordaining
people okay nicely dollars dad mr.
Corbyn thank you very much thank you